what is the FTX lesson for Traders but  also for exchanges Traders I think are  just going to be traded like they should  learn things I just don't think they're  going to they're going to keep training  what should they learn though it's just  don't keep your assets on the exchange  right off  is coinbase still around is it yes it is  I think that's the big lesson take your  stuff off the exchanges learn about  self-custody but like I used to say like  just take five dollars of Bitcoin and  move it into self-custody move it into  Cold Storage like learn how this stuff  works I can't even move that to my new  iPhone bro but that's why you should  start with five dollars is because you  didn't say that last time when I put 60  000 in for a Bitcoin  very reasonable